whoa
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
view feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by offset he's a
grammy-nominated platinum selling artist
you know is one third of me goes and
good news for offset fans is highly
anticipated often T's debut solo project
is on the way
offset welcome to the show off sick whoo
whoo let's do it so you're from Atlanta
where the chicken wing is king do you
order them spicy B crank it
I usually go up ma lemon pepper hot
lemon pepper be a little ooh hi talented
you know sometimes too much heat taking
something into taste
well offset we're gonna test you today
my man let's go
[Music]
you just going in uh-huh just go in I
[Music]
can tolerate yeah that's cool I like mom
mm-hmm right in your wheelhouse mm-hmm
so you made headlines last month for
walking in Paris Fashion Week in this
massive oversized off-white puffer coat
did you do anything to prepare for that
or just throw on clothes and take a lap
like you practice your walk or anything
um not in practice my walk well you know
I already got it in me and I always
wanted to be a part I did it before in
New York with Jeremy's tiny sky up so I
was familiar with its walk in Cuba
straight face keep your Sears keep it
professional not to play around they
don't play around with their stuff birds
have told me the way I need to go and I
went and I ain't not been I did my thing
on the topic of fashion what's the
backstory on your freakazoid piece
because that's a very niche cartoon to
be inspired by it frees lives to watch
freakazoid
when I was young and I just wanted to
get a character that people were not
always for me uh you gotta really know
your cartoons about freakazoid so I just
wanted to be cute a standout piece and
that's sir
and then finally what's your what's your
favorite piece of jewelry you're wearing
right now oh right now I'm afraid lots
to choose from
this is probably my watch this is the
automark we get it with baguette
diamonds around all the way around
Factory oh that's my favorite piece
right now I gots retail on that the cost
of life sometimes you don't put all you
be inside yeah
if we dip your gray out of Vermont let's
go so despite all the lyrics about pot
tech watches and flying private you get
a lot of credit behind the scenes for
your business savvy in fact the New York
Times described you as being obsessed
with music industry data watching do you
think that studying analytics makes it
easier for you to spot trends like
what's the information that you're
interested in the numbers match up to
what you are so you're worth go by the
numbers the lawyer numbers know you're
worth it's just how it is
so as an artist you know so many other
arts you can get lost your mind thinking
you somewhere else like I'm a big guy
actuality your numbers might not met so
I just be wanting to have my numbers to
match you gotta make sure you're
matching sizes then you'll be in denial
you won't know what your numbers are you
gotta know what your numbers are to
better
you know when John Mayer was on the show
he talked through chord progressions
that drive some of the biggest pop songs
I'm curious do you see any patterns and
what makes a rap hit yes the mido flow
see if you haven't noticed everything
that come on I've noticed you need no
that's like it's like life support is
like without it you can't it seems like
to me like without it at one point of
your career as an artist you're gonna
use that flow and with hip-hop being the
biggest shower sometimes these pop
artists these country artists come in
and then they don't really know how to
rap so they used that but still
harmonize on top of it so I feel like
just like the most effective in all
genres and then getting back to business
what are some of the dumbest things
young artists can do with their first
big bag of course buying jury and buying
cars because you know sometimes when you
confront when you're we don't have
things you know you want the material
things and so artists but sometimes it
can be an investment too but you can go
overboard because sometimes the look get
you more but you got to buy a house
worse in and put your mom and get some
on the right and make sure your
foundation is set before you blow the
bag
[Music]
patios poster Danville let's go down I
see what so ever it was for you dad
going in shallow sting to it one of our
favorite things to do is unpackage the
close relationship between professional
wrestling and hip-hop some curious what
was your reaction when you heard that
Ric Flair walked down the aisle to Ric
Flair drip at his wedding last year
first he hit me and told me yeah I'm not
a man I'm why he seriously fun to walk
his marriage listen to a rap song just
like a special moment you know use this
like a love song it's like a time of
love when I standing it last scene is
what he was just he was lit he's just
happy to be and for me meat heavy told
me it was one of the best things ever
happen to him because he was like he's
going through a little health issues he
was like that just gave him more driving
more driving more Drive and it was
inspirational to me because this looked
over to Ric Flair the Flair was the
first one would be keeping Rolexes and
these Jets believe the first one that I
seen talk about that stuff so when he
was the best let you know he's the best
your flat is never gonna Russell I
triphala whoo she booked cold okay it's
better give me a spicy so hot this thing
a dingy mm-hmm
so there's a huge amount of anticipation
for the new album and from what's been
reported it seems like the thing that
separates it from your work with me goes
is the degree to which you open up about
your personal life and I'm not here to
dig anything up but I am curious t I
went on a little rant on his last album
about how trap music needs to be about
all aspects of a trappers life including
falling in love and going on vacation is
that real or is that soft not as real
there's not no such thing soft we grow
them in so it's like it's real life
situations and we also are humans at the
same time so a lot of people try to
cover it up and then I can see why cuz
you got to protect it because you're
famous everything it's probably but it's
okay to show a vulnerable side as a man
he's like he's really it's really
a great thing to do as a man cuz most
men run from me so I feel like you
stronger man when you do that period
instead of holding back because it was
just holding back your feelings in
that's not true
we all got filled on card tough you
supposedly
those aliens days what is wrong we make
this one actually okay we'll stare down
I think I'm gonna go one number one two
three four or five halfway through ah
all right offset we have a recurrence
segment on our show called explain that
grammar we to a deep dive and I guess
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop I'll show you the picture and you
just tell me the bigger story is that
sound good sir let's do it all right
laptop please the nose one rule of nice
form bill first things first
how'd your chain end up on coach
Harbaugh haha visit the players
he's like a lucky girl I like your eyes
I see so we end up putting clay below
and take off put on the chain of peace
and again when I put the I style rule
that song and he just sat back you know
you know that's a legend right there you
see how he took your features just calm
and collected like he just knew what was
going on we've got the sauce listen the
way they used to throw that classic
throwback right there I was actually in
her video that's actually the video we
had to wear seats
dressed down she'd take a picture with
us which one is you I'm right here in
the hall great standing out with the hat
on
yeah dripped out on the side as you can
see since a young one I was probably a
designer didn't having trip yes sir
this right here is my part of my book
it's like the history like I do this
it's like that stamp line yeah I do this
how big any Chinese child
Mike all right Mike man he was cool dude
took us to the back show he got a crazy
pigeon cool his loves pigeon and you
could walk in he's like five or six
rooms just like it's crazy it's like I
think he said it's like 200 or 300
pigeons his house was beautiful he was
just giving us real stories on you know
sandwich to do with your money
don't mess up are you 20 all your 30s
you just give an OG game telling us
watch out for this and to do this and
make sure you be the best at what you do
that's Ellen the first time we ever did
hell is on I have an interesting story
Milan shout out to Ellen
when I came to the show I was supposed
to go to a dealership right after it
said go get the village when the truck
had just released when she came back
this morning I'm like I'm talking about
Bentley true she's like at the shop that
was like nah she's like I got somebody
in Italy and she referred Bentley and it
pulled up and when he pulled her after
the shoulder pull it up I just went to
the office and handled the business and
I paid for it so shot in the hell and
she got me to bed truck
she's the Bentley plug she's the club
just like that I thought she was playing
- she she was serious and she got police
money in the pitcher and got the most
money that's I like about the house
holding up 40 bucks and yes she's loaded
Santa Ella
[Music]
not to try to eat my food hmm
[Music]
get it out of their skull see you soon
mm-hmm I don't know if I like this one
low it got like a sweet it's kind of
sweet yeah like a little sweet sauce
mm-hmm yeah little island vibe so when
we had your labelmate Lil yadi on the
show we had a deep conversation about
his love for pizza which I'm told is
rivaled only by your love for breakfast
cereal is it true that you keep as many
as 50 boxes in the pantry at any given
time yeah see what happened is the
reason why I have so many now is cuz
some for some reason they just start
making exotic like new flavors of you
ever had a city of toast crunch Apple no
ah strawberry sauce crushed strawberry
then they got they got they got Lucky
Charms with nothing but the marshmallows
now it's just like they just step the
bar up so it's like I collect them cuz I
know it's called could they told me is
limited so I get like five blocks is eat
four keep one just a case yeah well you
know this cereal debate rages endlessly
on the internet so now that we have the
most credentialed cereal connoisseur and
hip-hop in front of us can you break it
down the top three cereals of all-time
top three series of all time
with Fruity Pebbles number 1 cinnamon
toast crunch
number 2 fruits I think they just the
top most classics classics and then you
know
migos had its own flavor of potato chips
for a while sour cream with a dab of
ranch have you given any thought to what
the offset cereal might be offset gypos
it'll come as a drip but then have a oh
and a little of money silent I've said
your bows yes are all green and white
and then I'm the topic of breakfast did
you know that there are over a hundred
and fifty waffle house locations in the
Atlanta area alone yeah I'm familiar
I've been to probably Harlow and the
chain gets name checked by everyone from
jay-z to future to me goes why is hip
hop so obsessed with Waffle House it's
just a late night breakfast joint two
three in the morning you pull up fresh
off the skillet it's not like fast food
breakfast we really I get to Texas milk
put a wife on the side you know Chad
baked chicken and cheese with bacon on
let's go whoa sense a change in your
demeanor offset
[Music]
whoa let go what we going so there's a
rich tradition of emcees rapping about
their attorneys but few are as closely
publicly connected as you and your
lawyer what can you tell the people
about hashtag billion-dollar lawyer you
did the business done talk Wow you get
the business dino go do a Stan you don't
play no his love he keep me positive it
says me invest my money and says me to
come to the house to eat dinner and you
pull up come over you see some of my
hair she cry he's not sure about college
yo he's like Big Brother and he had a
great quote in his New York Times
profile where he said if you can't hear
that bad and bougie is a classic try
again do you think a lawyer needs to
understand and listen to rap music in
order to successfully rap hip-hop
artists you got to know your culture you
got to be a part of it
you got to be a part of it if you're
gonna represent some you definitely have
to know what it is about
[Music]
huh beyond his salary
[Music]
how's that swallowing thing working out
[Music]
how many dogs do on these days mm 4 mm
can you name check them all on the spot
mmm bando
careful around your eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how you doing offset okay
find me my man find me my man cuz I just
need you to focus right now because
you're one you've joined the proud
fraternity of rap dog dad's and so with
that in mind I have a little pop quiz
for you on one side of this sheet there
are five dogs on the other side of this
sheet there are five rappers I'd like
for you to try to connect here's a pen
I'd like for you to try to connect the
dog to the rapper dad and you have 30
seconds 15 seconds okay let's check your
work do you feel confident about your
results here all right we have CJ
Thorton going to riff raff that's
incorrect CJ Thorton Pusha T Vincent
going to push a T but Vincent is
actually with Khalifa's dollar yep Jody
husky going to Wiz Kalifa but Jody husky
is actually riff Raff's dog trappy two
chains you got that one right but then
you put Clyde with currency when you got
that right so two first five
[Applause]
whoa so this one is Hellfire fear this
are you cold
Oh
[Music]
donut ah that's a set throw it in the
towel throwing in the towel is a great
effort was a great effort
whoo
let me let me be your cornerman for just
a second okay here's the thing I know
it's back in god it's back against the
ropes and you've taken some big punches
here but I see this spirited salute I
can't be no you know I'm saying
[Music]
so internet trends can sometimes spread
like a wildfire for no real reason and
you have unique perspective on that as
someone whose group is credited with
inspiring the dab
when did the jab die and who killed it
bad never dies because if you check
every game right now it's won a nice
name they stood Oh daddy never die you
know everything we do never it's the
last forever trends in the waves do you
want honesty
everybody say the way you see the way
he's caught wait I just it says win the
trans always it going it come back see
the bag of clothes I just left Paris
week it's back in trans and then your
confrontation with Joe Budden at last
year's BT Awards is maybe the most memed
moment and pop culture for a whole year
hey man you guys are nominated tonight
have a good show
is that something that you can look back
on now and laugh at it was I left that
after it was never it was never like ah
who's know that series you know I
learned that after taking this is the
funny part of it is the background
characters you know you have Julio Jones
you have Pierre Thomas did you see the
girl who paints her head up like that
yeah that's our Booker Kristin she
actually works on this show
Oh Charlotte Kirsten she's therefore a
legendary event
[Music]
you don't have to if you don't want to
know sure okay
all right offset ten chicken wings up
ten chicken wings down back against the
ropes and still able to fight on top of
it
the migos ad-libs the dictionary is so
robust that this point it could be an
international language now that the
brain is on fire
tongue ablaze I'm gonna ask you a series
of questions and I want you to respond
in just adlibs sigh let's go okay which
ad-lib would you use to describe your
new album huh
define your expectations for 2019 and a
single ad-lib you know what ad-lib would
you give the classic to bomb blast dab
and let me introduce humbly and ad-lib
and you tell me if it has legs hot ones
oh well look at you offset clearing the
board I know there was a time when your
back was against the ropes you didn't
think you could but you did it no
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my friend this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life it's re swell I'll sit one
third amigos I will be dropping an album
very soon it's gonna be I think one of
the best albums of 2019 I need you grind
me off this album yes sir
I mean hard-working let's get it
[Music]
you know like yeah it's yours to keep if
you want it sniff at your own risk
oh my de bomb pants going out hot ones
fans this is Sean Evans checking in to
say thank you so much for watching
today's episode and have a very exciting
Hot Sauce news update if you sign up for
the monthly subscription box in March
you will get boom a bottle of the
classic boom a bottle of Louis calientes
and double boom
the elusive scorpion edition of the last
dab is back in stock and available first
two hot ones monthly subscription box
subscribers and this is the best part
we're slashing prices everything must go
instead of the usual $40 $30 for this
all-star trio of hot ones hot sauces
heat nice calm for all your hot ones hot
sauce needs who appreciates you baby I
do